you'll be working with another Legend
Harrison Ford are you looking forward to
it he definitely is a legend and I just
want to go up and be like get off my
plane
get off my plane he must get that so
much I feel like he'd be he I don't
think he'd like me
but until that momentous meeting
happened
all about sharper stop he's not a cop
this is what my son does he plays these
games all that work for one thousand
dollars one of the great things about
this film is it focuses on money the
power of money what is the craziest job
you've ever had to make money I took
tickets at an amusement park and they
told me that if someone strikes me that
I can't fight back
that was pretty crazy but no one struck
me
I was a camp counselor at a Sleepaway
Camp for kids from 8 to 18 and that was
kind of anxiety inducing I used to go to
NYU and volunteered in like these
psychology classes
for like you know hundreds of us here
and there yeah and they would evaluate
like my uh I guess mine
yeah well that's good if you're gonna
steal
steal a lot
who would make a better con artist John
Lithgow or Julianne Moore
yeah give it to me John is so nice that
like I was like there has to be one
dangerous bone
how do you think it stands
not well
foreign